Speaker 1: Let's look at the latest.
I mean, it's like to call it a conspiracy
theory is almost like too much because it
suggests there's some theory and there really
isn't.
A Newsmax reporter suggested during a recent
White House press briefing that the entire
Delta variant might be almost like a false
flag.
It might not really be a thing.
This took place during an outrageously chaotic
press briefing, this press briefing.
So let me set this up for you, because the
entire scene was absolute and total bedlam.
Jen Psaki did not hold this press briefing.
This press briefing was held by the deputy
press secretary, Kathryn Jean Pierre, who
did overall a very good job.
Towards the end of the press conference, there
was this idea.
They do this every once in a while.
They'll bring on a reporter via video conference
to ask a question.
Sometimes it's like a rural reporter.
Once it was someone from Alaska.
OK, so they try to bring on this reporter
remotely.
And there's just massive technical issues
like we the viewers at home could hear the
reporter.
But I guess in the room they couldn't hear
the reporter.
And then the reporter was talking at the same
time.
Newsmax reporter starts talking about the
Delta variant and it gets nuts.
So I'm still wondering why news, Max, is even
in the White House press briefing room.
I never I still can't fully understand how
that works.
We've heard before, oh, someone has lost the
seat, but they're still in there at the back
yelling questions.
It's not totally transparent to me.
There's some opacity here.
OK, but let's get to it.
And again, I'm warning you, it's total and
complete chaos in the room.
Like, it's really hard to figure out what's
going on and what's even being said.
But let's make an attempt to figure it out.
Speaker 2: When there's a train in the area
where people just test whatever, we don't,
we don't we.
Speaker 1: OK, so the question there and by
the way, I don't know if you saw seems to
so so far the mask is off the nose and soon
you'll see the mask actually come all the
way down.
The question is, how can you say the Delta
variant is spreading when when people get
tested, it's just are you positive or are
you negative for covid?
That's the question.
It's all sort of like is is the Delta variant
even really a thing?
Speaker 2: People just test whatever they're
covered.
We don't we don't we don't test.
We don't test.
We have a sense of public health.
The scientists only tell us that it's a Delta
variant for that.
I don't know, even on.
And why would they explain their process and
how they're turning against the.
I mean, that's what they are telling us, I
laid out why I laid out how contagious it
was and I laid out why why we needed to
Speaker 1: this this is this is so frustrating.
I'm with you guys.
Speaker 2: Delta variant.
I laid out a lot of what the answer is.
We get hit because they say so without a lot.
What they're the experts.
It's not it's not just date so far.
Speaker 1: I guess what she's saying is, how
do we know if something is the Delta variant,
if I have symptoms and I go and get tested
and it's sir, you're positive, right, sir?
Speaker 3: Sure.
Speaker 1: I how does is it Delta or is it
not Delta?
The explanation is you sequence the virus,
you get a cohort that's representative of
the population and you test them and you sequence
the virus.
You don't do this with everybody.
And sort of like when you when you do a political
poll, you don't interview every American,
you get a representative sample.
And so the idea would be if 40 percent of
the sample believes something, then you can
extrapolate that roughly 40 percent of the
country believes something.
If your sample is good, it's the same thing
with the sequencing that their test cohorts
and if they see that 80 percent of the test
cohort is the Delta variant, then you can
say, well, Delta's probably 80 percent of
the country's positive test.
Generally speaking, if your sample is good,
like she seems to be saying, why isn't Korean
jumpier explaining epidemiology to her?
So therefore, it must all be some kind of
false flag.
It continues.
Speaker 2: These are scientists.
These are experts.
I just said, hold on one second.
I hold on one second.
I just said that.
Lewinsky said just recently in her 20 year
career, she had never seen a variant that
was so contagious.
So this is 20 years of her career.
Speaker 1: I actually don't think Korean Jumpier
is doing that great of a job here, unfortunately.
Speaker 2: So this is absolutely, absolutely
a major, major problem that we are trying
to deal with.
That's why we heard from the president yesterday.
That's what we keep talking about.
People need to get vaccinated.
So that is that is that is the way that we're
trying to move in this administration, making
sure that we are protecting people here, making
sure that we're dealing with this pandemic
in a way that is effective and that's how
we're going to move forward.
I'll take another
Speaker 1: question for you.
So, you know, there's I mean, what's frustrating
about this is, first of all, it doesn't really
matter what you call it, like whatever you
call it, even if you don't even talk about
variance, it has gotten way more contagious
that you would call it whatever you want.
You don't need to sequence every case.
You need to sequence a representative sample.
If you want to say, wow, Delta now dominant
in Florida, you're not sequencing every individual.
You're saying let's take a cohort.
And it used to be that five percent of the
cohort was Delta and now 80 percent, so that
it's becoming dominant.
The logic here from the reporter is sort of
like, if you've not exactly explained how
gravity works, then I should be able to fly.
Like, maybe people can fly because you're
not explaining to me exactly how gravity works.
If you've not tested gravity, it maybe it
doesn't actually apply here.
Maybe it's made up.
And Corrine's expression, you know, it's funny.
It's sort of like a combination of confusion
and pure hatred.
It would have been better for her to be a
little more prepared because to you and me
were like, oh, my God, it's like this is not
an epidemiology briefing.
We're testing a cohort.
And that's sort of it to the conspiracy theorists
that comes off like the Newsmax reporter made
a really good point.
And there's this incredible arrogance in there
about like if the Newsmax reporter doesn't
understand it, how could anyone and therefore,
is it even definitely true.
And it's like a combination of belief based
on ignorance and Dunning Kruger, they don't
understand the science.
They assume that they do, and therefore they
assume that if the science was good, they
would understand it, but they don't.
And so when they encounter some kind of information
that challenges their preconceptions or they
don't get it, but you get a positive or a
negative when you get tested.
So how could we know anything about Delta
then all of a sudden it reinforces their beliefs
that they shouldn't trust what's going on.
You know, it's sort of like, hey, Kareen,
can you explain the field of epidemiology
in the press briefing room?
Oh, you can't.
Well, then there must be no delta.
And with a lot of this, you know, it's like
start from the way I would suggest dealing
with people like this in your private life.
And we've talked about this before.
Start from are you open to the idea that you
might not know everything and I might not
know everything?
Oh, OK.
Good.
If you're open to that, then we can go to
the next thing.
What reason do you have to doubt that there
is a different variant now than at the beginning?
Like, do you have general doubt about the
fact that viruses change over time?
Do you have specific doubt about how this.
Right.
And really try to break down where the disconnect
is.
But everything just seems totally confusing
to this reporter.
She doesn't know how to wear a mask.
It shouldn't shock us that she also doesn't
understand.
You test a cohort and then you extrapolate
from it's really a sad state of affairs, my
friends not.
Sad is the fact that we are now under two
weeks from our 16th anniversary, 16 years
since the start of The David Pakman Show will
be doing a one day membership special on Monday,
August 16th.
I would love for you to sign up on that day.
It's going to be an incredible day.
It's going to be an historic day.
You can sign up for our newsletter at David
Pakman Dotcom.
And then Monday morning on the 16th, you'll
get an email telling you how to sign up at
a huge discount.